رغم تعرضه للتهديدات لوقف التقليد الساخر
واثار الجدل بظهوره في عده دول شبيه
الزعيم كيم جونغ يظهر من جديد في كاس
العالم تداول رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقاطع فيديو لشبيه كم وورد اكس
من امام ستاد خليفه الدولي في الدوحه وهو
يلوح بيده للجمهور الذي يتجمع حوله والتقط
معه صورا تذكاريه
كشفت الداخليه المصريه في مجال مكافحه
جرائم الاموال العامه كنزا سريا داخل فيلا
في حي اكتوبر يحتوي على سبائك ذهبيه واكثر
من مليونين دولار مزوره حيث مذكره تفاصيل
ضبط اخطر المزودين الذين تربحوا من نشاطهم
المشبوه قرابه 20 مليون جنيه والنصب على
مواطنين راغبين في شراء العملات الاجنبيه
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو متداول الهندي
اطول نسخه القران مكتوب بخط اليد بطوله
22 مترا
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم